hoy vamos a hablar de un tema realmente
interesante hoy nos vamos a acercar
hasta la revolución de las rosas un
proceso político que consiguió que muy
poco tiempo todo un país pasase de
sentirse orgulloso de ser la tierra
natal de stalin
honrar a ronald reagan es enrique
georgia ha protagonizado el proceso de
reformas políticas y económicas más
ambiciosos de los últimos 50 años y
singapur ni corea del sur ni irlanda
realizaron tantos cambios en tan poco
tiempo hoy vamos a verlo
y 11 es un pequeño país a orillas del
mar negro cuya historia se remonta hasta
el año 700 antes de cristo y ya desde el
siglo 11 es un estado unificado como hoy
lo conocemos su elemento más
característico es sin duda su idioma
tostado y son tratadas de aliento y que
acá el texto y sobre todo su alfabeto el
alfabeto georgiano que es utilizado por
menos de 5 millones de personas de todo
el mundo y que a nosotros nos puede
resultar realmente extraño y sin embargo
en nuestra historia comienza el día 9 de
abril de 1991 y el día en que georgia se
independizó de la extinta unión
soviética
en ese momento cuando los habitantes de
este país tuvieron que recordar
preguntas que habían permanecido en el
olvido por más de 70 años que producir
cómo producir y a quién vender además
este pequeño país vio como sus
instituciones se desmoronaban por
completo y en apenas unos meses sufrió
un derrocamiento de un gobierno el
regreso al poder de un antiguo jerarca
de la unión soviética el fracaso militar
de su ejército en la sublevación de
osetia del sur y un estallido armado en
la región de asia donde 250000 georgia
nos sufrieron una auténtica persecución
en mitad
cuatro años después de la independencia
su producto interior bruto se había
desplomado un 78% la corrupción el
crimen organizado y el régimen
autoritario del presidente de barna che
se hicieron con el poder
de esta forma llegamos a 2003 año en el
que se produce la revolución de las
rosas pero antes de empezar a dar dinero
es importante destacar dos personajes
claves de este acontecimiento por un
lado el personaje saliente eduard
shevarnadze quien llevaba más de 30 años
controlando prácticamente georgia
curiosamente la actividad política de
este hombre se enmarca más fuera de
georgia dentro porque fue nada más y
nada menos que ministros entre los
exteriores de la unión soviética del 85
91 la mano derecha de gorbachov y uno de
los impulsores de la perestroika
y luego tenemos por otro lado el
personaje entrante mijaíl saakashvili
abogado de prestigio en estados unidos
quien convenció curiosamente su carrera
política de la mano de eduard
shevarnadze si es que mira es gay fue
ministro de justicia con este hombre
pero ahora es que no acabaron nada bien
en su relación porque siendo ministro
quiso impulsar una ley que perseguía
fermento de la corrupción hasta tal
punto que si alguien no podía probar de
dónde había obtenido un bien si no podía
pagar su origen el estado y va a
embargar ese bien
la verdad es que la oligarquía no aceptó
de buen grado esta propuesta y se
rechazó
tras este desencuentro sagas vil y
abandona el gobierno ese balance e
inicia su oposición política al mismo
llegando a los comicios de noviembre de
2003 con un respaldo social importante
sin embargo contra toda encuesta con
todo pronóstico los retos oficiales
señalan como ganador a shevarnadze as
saakashvili no nos compra habla de
fraude democrático y sale a la calle
junto a sus simpatizantes llegando a
tomar incluso el día 22 del mismo mes el
hemiciclo durante es la primera votación
del mismo tras este incidente tras este
acontecimiento shevarnadze decidió
renunciar a la presencia del gobierno y
convocar nuevas elecciones
curiosamente entre 2004 se repite las
selecciones y sagas billy obtiene un
apoyo de más del 96 por ciento contando
32 votantes
curiosamente con shevarnadze incluso con
semejante apoyo no es extraño que el
gobierno es más vil y puede sacar
adelante como antes nos comentaba
alberto un plan de reformas realmente
intenso reformas que pueden clasificarse
en tres puntos principales el primero de
ellos el que a mí más me gusta la
liberalización de la economía
empezando por cambiar el sistema fiscal
pasando de un sistema farragoso con
muchísimos impuestos a un sistema con
sólo seis impuestos con tipos bajos y
además muy simple que se podía resumir
en cuatro folios cuando los impuestos
son bajos y además son fáciles de pagar
la evasión fiscal pierde su sentido pues
el gobierno de saakashvili consiguió
bajando impuestos recaudar en pocos años
seis veces más dinero multiplicó la
recaudación por seis con lo cual había
más dinero para educación en sanidad
el segundo punto fue enmendar la
constitución que introdujeron la
denominada ley libertad el gasto público
quedaba limitado un 30 por ciento del
propio tributo y ojo lo más importante
cualquier subida de impuestos tenía que
ser aprobada por la ciudadanía mediante
referéndum y que eso en españa como un
toro no lo hemos tenido desgraciadamente
y a mí me parece fenomenal que la gente
pueda opinar directamente
el segundo punto clave también todo este
proceso fue la privatización de empresas
públicas y privatización además mediante
subasta de tal forma que cualquier
persona de georgia o extranjero pudiesen
comprar los activos públicos de hecho
hay un aliento tales que la primera
empresa privatizada por el gobierno fue
un complejo turístico en la ciudad de
batumi un oligarca local acostumbrado a
comprar cosas públicas le ofrece el
govern 80 mil dólares y sacas bill y
dijo no lo sacó a subasta y obtuvo más
de 3 millones de euros
último punto de las reformas combatir la
corrupción y reducir el peso del estado
la dimensión del estado pues con todo
esto que seas vil cambió por completo el
programa geo y lo convirtió en una de
las economías más libres del cáucaso y a
niveles prácticamente occidentales y con
ello llegó la prosperidad no está mal
verdad siete añitos
bueno bueno hay que decir también que
andy que es un poco forofo deshagas bill
igual no es oro todo lo que reluce este
hombre también tiene sus lados oscuros
por ejemplo en 2008 para terminar con la
sublevación de la región de osetia del
sur no dudó en atacar y hacer uso de las
armas
hay una excusa a rusia nada justificable
pero desde luego ya sabemos cómo es
putin entró con todo su peso invadió
georgia sino que también se destruyó de
infraestructuras claves para el país por
la verdad es que al final el balance fue
bastante negativo
otro episodio bastante oscuro fue en
2007 las soluciones para físicamente
alguien que haya llegado al poder
tratado de denunciar un fraude
democrático pues parece que no fueron
del todo limpias por su parte y su
situación actual es ya de película
porque ahora mismo sakashvili no es
ciudadano georgiano ha renunciado a su
nacionalidad ahora mismo es ucraniano y
es gobernador de una región de ucrania
nada más y nada menos la justicia de
georgia le busca desde luego daría para
una miniserie todo eso que cuentas es
verdad alberto pero yo es que parte de
la premisa de que ningún político es el
mesías
ah
no obstante asaja es vil y no le tembló
la mano y las reformas introdujeron más
libertad y más competitividad y
prosperidad en georgia y eso me parece
fundamental yo reconozco que son
nominados a recibir y sobre todo creo
que el futuro de georgia es muy
prometedor es decir si el gobierno
mantiene la senda de competitividad del
libre mercado y de desarrollo de
sectores de la economía que implantó
saakashvili
me parece que georgia va a dar mucho hay
que hablar y va a ser en pocos años uno
de los países de moda bueno por ahora
fichado en ucrania luego de que lo que
habrá que hacer es esperar para ver si
está la estrella de georgia acaba siendo
tan prometedora como puede parecer o no
desde luego estaremos nosotros atentos a
la actualidad que desde allí nos nos
llega si tiene algún comentario si
tienes cualquier aportación que realizar
por favor no dudéis en hacerlo si bueno
desgraciadamente se van a que ya no se
cuente nosotros pero bueno si tiene una
amistad que es prevista en today
si quiere hacemos cualquier aclaración
la recibiremos con mucho gusto un saludo
y hacemos un vídeo